[Music]
the views and opinions expressed on this
program
are those of the guests appearing on the
program and do not necessarily reflect
the views and opinions of eight news now
or next our media group
if it involves you know any tempering of
the mail then we definitely would
have a part in that investigation
tonight on politics now
ensuring nevada's election security how
the mail is being closely watched by
federal agents
plus this president hasn't done anything
to get
done he's just walked away the i-team
sits down with democratic presidential
candidate joe biden on his coronavirus
plan
nevada get your governor to open up your
state
and president donald trump holds a rally
just over the nevada border in arizona
why his campaign rallied there instead
of las vegas
from eight news now this is politics now
we are just three days away from
election day thank you for joining us
here on politics now i'm john langler
turnout has been big for this very
unusual election
by the time all of the ballots are
counted nevada will have passed one
million early votes this year
before election day the turnout is
already more than 53 percent
so here are some numbers through
thursday so far in nevada more than 985
000 people have voted 478 000 voted in
person
another half a million by mail here in
clark county more than 680 000
people have already voted the break is
split nearly down the middle
with half in person and half by mail
more than 342 000 early votes have been
cast and most of those all again
by mail the next question voter turnout
across nevada about 45 thousand 500 more
democrats have turned in ballots than
republicans
78 000 of those democratic votes here in
clark county
so it may take a big republican turnout
on election day
or a big share of independence for the
gop to win nevada
this week was packed with visits from
presidential candidates in their
surrogates
on wednesday president donald trump held
a rally across the colorado river in
bullhead city arizona
kristen drummond explains why the
president is trying to appeal to
nevadans from across the border
several thousand people coming to the
loughlin bullhead international airport
on wednesday
president donald trump coming here to
pitch nevada voters from arizona
because of the silver state's current
social gathering restrictions
he did what he had to do to get a good
size rally at a
close enough location to las vegas
chanson cheers for president trump as he
steps off air force one the
commander-in-chief crossed campaigns at
the airport
less than a week from election day how
many people are from
nevada not bad
the president rallying voters across the
banks of the colorado river from
laughlin
choosing to come here because governor
steve siselek continues to cap crowd
capacity at 250 people
president trump is returning to the
region after violating crowd
restrictions at rallies in nevada last
month
including in henderson but some say this
venue allows supporters from around the
west
to see him stump on the campaign trail
and avoid violation
you get people from arizona nevada
california i've even heard about people
from idaho here so it's a good central
location
trump speaking more than an hour to the
crowd topics included the economy second
amendment the border wall
questioning his opponent former vice
president joe biden
and coveted restrictions in nevada but
nevada
get your governor to open up your state
please
get him to open up your state president
donald trump immediately left on air
force one to attend
another airport rally in goodyear
arizona about 20 minutes from phoenix
reporting from bullhead city kristen
drummond 8 news now
now we have requested interviews
one-on-one with president trump so far
his campaign has not made him available
meanwhile the i-team's vanessa murphy
did speak with his challenger joe biden
on zoom this week
nevada has been hit so hard by
unemployment
what would a biden administration do to
address that and
and not a promise but an immediate
action
well first of all an immediate action
requires us to get the virus under
control
one of the things one of the reasons why
i think nevada's being hit so hard in
terms of employment
is because there is fact people aren't
coming to nevada
they aren't coming to nevada you're not
filling up your hotels you're not
the gaming industry the whole you're a
gigantic part of your industry
is hosting people from around the
country and they're not able to move
number one number number two i would
make sure in the meantime
immediately to deal with it is i would
make sure where i the president and i
won't be able to do this until i'm
elected if it occurs
and that is make sure that we passed in
the law
and passed on to nevada and the
employees there
exactly what the house has already
passed unemployment insurance
rent insurance making sure you don't get
not getting thrown out of your
out of your home or your apartment
making sure your mortgage you're able to
be paid
all the things that were passed by the
house representatives this president
hasn't done
anything to get done he's just walked
away
and as and thirdly one of the things
that when i ran the recovery act when we
had that great recession when we
inherited
from the bush administration back when
brock and i got elected
i was able to get 88 billion dollars out
the door but part of the
ada actually 81 out the door without any
waste or fraud but one of the first
things we did
we provided over 140 billion dollars of
state and local governments
because they have to balance their
budgets and so what happens when they
have to balance their budget they're
laying off
police officers firefighters first
responders
school teachers and all the rest and i
would get the house has already passed
legislation to provide
direct help to the state and local
governments to keep people employed
to keep businesses employed keep
businesses open
get people paid in that extra 600 bucks
all those things that republicans
are not doing and quite frankly mitch
mcconnell used the phrase
when he talked about the state of
affairs in the states he said let them
go bankrupt
so i would move what is already there
and i'd move it quickly immediately
the casinos and conventions support our
economy and we do
see some of the casinos some of the
casino floors
are busy at times right now but our
covet numbers
are are going up i'm not connecting the
two
but but what would you do what would
your administration's
role be with the states and a state like
nevada
first of all i said i i believe that one
of the reasons why
the casino floors aren't full and the
hotels aren't full
is because the rest of the nation is
being bombarded
and clobbered by covet we're having we
had 83
000 new cases in one day on last
friday and then on monday another 83 000
new cases deaths are piling up we've
already had 225 000
deaths so what i would do is start to
listen to the science
we paid two pri higher price for donald
trump's chaotic and divisive tenure so
far
over 1700 nevadans have died from and
over 97
000 have been affected nearly 200 000
are out of job
and 98 of the culinary union members are
out of work
statewide employment what i think you
got the highest or one of the second
highest in the nation
it's 12 point something percent if i'm
not mistaken
and nevada's businesses are closing your
schools aren't back to normal because
he can't focus on what matters he's
failed to pull the leaders together
hammer out a deal
to for working people mom and dad mom
and pop stores to be able to stay open
democratic house passed a bill all the
way back in may
that they call the heroes act and so
what i'd be doing is getting the money
out
immediately to help those businesses
stay open
to be able to pay their employees to be
able to provide for
i'll give you one example we can open
schools but it's going to cost about 200
billion dollars overall
for in the entire united states because
you got to provide
the ventilation systems in the schools
you got to the sanitary systems
you got to provide for smaller classes
more teachers
you got to provide for the separation
that it relates to
in terms of plexiglas all the things we
can do where it's being done
they're able to open and people aren't
getting sick
former vice president and current
democratic presidential nominee joe
biden they're talking to vanessa murphy
so the vice presidential candidates were
in nevada this week both of them were
democratic candidate kamala harris
she was in reno followed by a socially
distanced rally at the doolittle
community complex
in the historic west side of las vegas
she was joined there by congresswoman
susie lee
and congressman stephen horsford both of
them of course up for reelection
meanwhile vice president mike pence he
held a rally at reno's airport on
thursday
the people who were there were required
to sign an agreement and the organizers
had to maintain
it would be limited to 250 people the
vice president was joined on stage by
congressman mark amade
who was also up for reelection here in
nevada meanwhile the trump campaign and
the republican party have filed two
separate lawsuits against clark county
and state election officials
at a hearing in court on wednesday a
judge denied the request by the
plaintiffs to stop
counting ballots that lawsuit alleges
signature verification scanners are set
too low a second suit requests
information about election workers in
clark county
and that information includes the
political affiliations of clark county's
bipartisan signature verification board
both lawsuits are working their way
through the courts and they're not
expected though to stall the election
next on politics now making our election
secure
i am unaware of any um incredible
reports of any voter fraud being
committed through the mail
a postal inspector talks to the i-team
about election day precautions
and fundraising for the bench why the
district attorney in clark county is
getting involved in a race
welcome back to politics now
one race that you've probably seen ads
for is nevada's next supreme court
justice
it's one of more than 130 seats on the
bench statewide in this election cycle
but it's also the one getting the most
attention the i-team's david charns
discovered one
contribution raising questions about
independence between prosecutors
and the bench you've seen the ads
i'm judge doug herndon i'm ozzie fumo
and i'm running for nevada state supreme
court assemblyman ozzy fumo and clark
county district court judge doug herndon
vying for an open state supreme court
seat the i-team found
they're getting help to get there
campaign finance reports show hundreds
of thousands of dollars flowing in from
lawyers and big name law firms
even the clark county district attorney
some who could one day show up in front
of the bench
the nevada bar prohibits a lawyer from
quote seeking to influence a judge by
means prohibited by law
it basically prevents a lawyer from
bribing a judge but campaign donations
to a judge
who could one day try your case that's
perfectly legal
both campaigns say it's not about the
money but remaining
independent in the courtroom it's all
about integrity
and if you have it nothing else matters
and if you don't have it
nothing else matters you've either got
the ability to be independent
or you don't and if you're going to be
not independent then you have no
business being in court period
a 2015 report from the brennan center
for justice finds
63 percent of donations made to supreme
court candidates nationwide
comes from lawyers lobbyists and other
business interests
in all from small donations to the ten
thousand dollar cap fumo has raised 336
thousand dollars
to herndon's 776 thousand it raises
questions about at the very least
perception dr francis carlton is a
political science professor at the
college of southern nevada
he says the constitution protects
donations as a form of free speech
you have one side before the judge
that's given a contribution and the
other side hasn't
right that's that's when it can be most
problematic so how could the campaign
for clark county district attorney steve
wolfson
donate 25-hundred dollars to herndon's
campaign
judge herndon says the two men are
longtime colleagues
i don't think that impacts my ability to
be impartial and i don't think
look 2500 is a lot of money obviously
but i don't think in the context of a
campaign
it's an amount of money that would make
anybody say wow you can't be impartial
now because you know that guy gave you
that much money
in a statement wolfson said in part my
support is determined by my personal
knowledge of the candidate's
qualifications
in my belief that they are the best
choice to fill the position adding
nothing bars him from supporting one
candidate over the other
it comes in a sense a leap of faith that
is not
inaccurate to say that carlton says
because the law is clear
donations to judicial campaigns are
legal we simply have to put our trust
in an independent court once you have
those you're going to have the issue of
campaign contributions
david charns 8 news now on top of
donations made to the candidates
political action committees or pacs can
indirectly finance these candidates as
well
both fumo and judge herndon say they're
aware of at least one pack working in
their favor
pumping even more money into that race
so with the election just days away
president donald trump
he is still questioning the integrity of
nevada's election the i-team has been
digging deeper into the issue
and found answers from one law
enforcement agency you don't often hear
about
vanessa murphy has that story you only
see on eight news now
president donald trump in bullhead city
arizona wednesday
continued to undermine confidence in the
election process
in nevada particularly mail-in ballots
they're an option for all active
registered voters in the state during
the covid 19 pandemic
we're a little concerned with all those
ballots floating around in nevada
got a lot of ballots floating around in
nevada an issue his campaign has been
pushing
voter fraud from your department's
perspective
is voter fraud widespread through the
mail
no as of right now i am unaware of any
incredible reports of any voter fraud
being committed through the mail
and that's something postal inspector
trevor hudson would look into
if it involves you know any tempering of
the male then we definitely would have a
part in that investigation
he's part of a team in las vegas we're a
federal law enforcement agency so
we you know we carry guns we
make arrests we serve search warrants
it's an agency more people are becoming
familiar with after its role in the
arrest of former trump adviser steve
bannon and
in the lead-up to november third one of
our missions as a postal inspector is to
protect the security of the mail
so that's something that we're trying to
do and something that we we do all the
time so that's you know something we'll
continue to do through the election
five days from the election the u.s
attorney's office sent
eight news now a news release from the
department of justice
about protecting voter rights and about
resources being used to
investigate election fraud now in
addition to the postal inspector telling
us
there are no credible reports of voter
fraud
i recently talked with the head of the
fbi of las vegas
he also said voter fraud is not
widespread
nevada has secure voting machines and he
wants voters
to feel confident vanessa murphy 8 news
now
if you believe you've been the victim of
a postal related crime you can file a
report the number is in the bottom of
your screen
you're 877-876-2455 politics now
amy coney barrett sworn in as the 115th
supreme court justice earlier this week
she is the fifth woman on the high
court the white house ceremony was just
moments after the senate confirmed
judge barrett 52-48 on monday
the senate has now adjourned until after
the election
across the country record turnout is
expected this election day many states
like nevada have expanded mail
or early voting nevada changed the law
this year to start counting
15 days before election day but that's
not the case in other states like
michigan
we're trying to manage expectations now
to say when the system works
uh when people are counting ballots
effectively and efficiently and
carefully and accurately
that takes time it can't be done
instantly
let's start by talking about what
election day what it's going to look
like how long will we have to wait
to see the ultimate results yeah that's
the big unknown we have though been
talking to
election officials in states around the
country and the message that they
basically have is that they want the
public to be prepared to have to wait
perhaps a few days perhaps a few weeks
we really don't know
and there are a couple of issues at play
one of them is that we are already
seeing
record numbers of people vote either by
mail
or early in person in states that allow
that so there's already a larger volume
the other issue is the vote by mail the
thing is that
some states you know they're allowed to
pre-process
all of these ballots that they're
getting in the mail here in virginia for
example election officials told me they
can run
the ballots as they get them and then on
election night
all they do is essentially push a button
to get the the tally to that point
but other states they're not allowed to
do that at all they cannot begin any
type of pre-processing
until election day or maybe the day
before
um so that's something that election
officials in michigan for example are
really concerned about and it could take
them
days perhaps weeks to catch up and count
all of those ballots that they got ahead
of time
what concerns are there on capitol hill
about the role
and other people involved in the
election the concern of the role they're
going to play
after election day we've kind of focused
a lot on the messaging on social media
leading up to the election
and whether or not there's political
bias on these platforms that's been a
huge um you know issue here that
lawmakers have focused on on capitol
hill
but it was really interesting because
this week there was a hearing in the
senate with the ceos
of twitter alphabet which is google
and facebook and mark zucker mark
zuckerberg actually said that in the
days after the election
facebook will actually be flagging any
candidates or any posts
that claim victory in any races that
have not
actually been decided and he said that
the way that will happen is that the
flag will have an attachment and maybe
some sort of link
that explains that actually this race is
still ongoing
it's not been completed states are still
counting
that was our washington dc correspondent
alexandra limon
so for results here in nevada we started
counting 15 days early but
ballots still have to be postmarked by
november 3rd and then election officials
will have to wait up to seven
days for the mail-in ballots to actually
arrive again depending on when they've
been postmarked so final certified
results will come about a week
after the election however you still may
know who won many of the races
on election night depending on how big
the gap is and how much of a vote we get
on
election eve the question is though are
you ready for election day
we're going to tell you about some of
the coverage plans and when you might
expect all the results
well what we're keeping an eye on next
week have you heard it's election day
first we do want to remind you there is
same-day registration available in
nevada
and also you do not have to go to a
specific polling place this year
if you are voting in person just head to
the one that's closest to you the
polling location
we're gonna have team coverage at the
polls on election day
here on eight news now and of course at
eightnewsnow.com
we're also going to have election
experts joining us steve sibelius from
the rj
he's going to join us for our coverage
and we'll bring you candidates who are
involved in the election
via zoom all throughout election day we
start
on air at four o'clock in the afternoon
next on tuesday rather
from four to seven and after that we're
going to give up to the minute updates
online
and on television every half hour we
have an eight o'clock results special on
our digital platforms
and a wrap-up program at 11 o'clock on
election night
if you're still unsure about a few races
and you haven't voted yet or if you want
to see candidates position on a certain
issue
don't forget to check out our 2020
election interviews section at
eightnewsnow.com
we have all of the interviews that we
have done with the candidates and the
top campaign officials in all the major
races
and political analysts as well it's all
in one easy spot
just uh check it out we've got the
presidential and the congressional
candidates as well
just look for the tab under news for
everything you need to know
please make sure you vote we'll have a
complete recap of election day on
politics now next week have a good rest
of the week